y puede que sólo estemos a mediados de
junio pero francia se encamina hacia
temperaturas abrasadoras en los próximos
días que normalmente no se registran
hasta julio o agosto en una ola
extraordinariamente temprana e intensa
se espera que las temperaturas alcancen
los 40 grados celsius en la capital
francesa y los parisinos ya se están
preparando para el intenso calor
el año pasado tuvimos un verano bastante
malo ahora en junio ya estamos a 37
grados y es cierto que las temperaturas
no son como su estómago creo que el
mayor problema de parís es que está
demasiado urbanizada y hormigonada y se
siente el calor de forma diferente
también es duro vivir en apartamentos
suele hacer mucho calor o mucho frío y
sentimos el calor muy intensa mejoras al
auto los expertos afirman que estos
períodos de calor abrazador que ahora se
producen mucho antes y con más
frecuencia de lo normal tienen su origen
en el cambio climático la ola de calor
está relacionada con el aire caliente
que sube desde el norte de áfrica a
través de la península ibérica y que va
a seguir expandiéndose
si es una señal del calentamiento global
eso es obviamente provocado por la
actividad humana es un abanico de aire
caliente vemos a esta zona muy caliente
en francia- que luego a partir del
domingo se trasladará al centro de
europa italia los alpes y el sur de
alemania también se verá afectado
guillermo el calor sofocante se produce
cuando la vecina españa está registrando
las temperaturas más altas de las
últimas dos décadas antes del verano y
cuando francia ha vivido su mes de mayo
más caluroso desde 1931 la capital
francesa registró su día más caluroso de
todos los tiempos en julio de 2019
alcanzando los 42 grados